frantic shoppers rushed to south
america's largest shopping mall
their last chance before they and
millions of other chileans go
into lockdown rodriguez needed to buy a
birthday present for her niece
my daughter works in a clinic and says
the number of patients is out of control
this is a necessary measure although
many don't believe it
despite a mass inoculation campaign the
number of critical care patients is the
highest since the pandemic began
and the new restrictions more stringent
than ever before
only two police permits per week to buy
food and medicine
and a total nationwide lockdown without
permits on weekends
the aim is to keep 75 percent of the
population at home until after easter
and reduce infections enough to allow
national elections to take place
in two weeks but there's no guarantee
south america is facing a fierce
resurgence of infections
and deaths in neighboring peru relatives
of 80-year-old martin kispe
prepare to bury him he died at home
because there were no beds left in
hospitals
81 year old felicita pimental is one of
the few lucky ones who's been able to
get vaccinated
many people are dying every day i lost
two children
one who was 48 years old and 150
recently from covet 19.
one year after people were literally
dying on the streets from the virus in
ecuador
hospitals are again on the brink of
collapse
further north in venezuela the
government has ordered a two-week
lockdown after having relaxed
confinement measures
because of the sudden spike in
infections and severe shortages of
critical care units
the volume of patients is increased in
this new wave and there are more serious
cases than last year
even in uruguay which until now was not
regarded as a coveted hotspot
the government has tightened
anti-pandemic measures because of a
sharp surge in cases
schools gyms and most public offices
will be closed until april 12th
the president however says he does not
believe in lockdowns
we have refused and we continue to do so
because it is more a matter of principle
than a practice
and fortunately our principles are
especially in this case
the ones we believe we have to apply to
move the country forward
whatever the containment strategy the
entire continent is struggling to obtain
and distribute vaccinations with the
exception of chile
and even here it hasn't been fast enough
to prevent a new
deadly viral wave to lucia newman al
jazeera santiago